second question
thank you pastor the second question is
in is genesis
15 verse 4 to 5
spiritual or literal why was god
what was god's purpose for calling
abraham
is genesis 15 verse 4
to 5 45 spiritual or literal
yeah that's when god told abraham that
he would have a seed from his own bowels
because abraham at that point he had no
child and he was
he was questioning god he said behold to
me that has given no seed or no
air and more no one born in my house is
mine
and the word of god came into him saying
this shall not be thine air but he that
cometh out of thine own bowels shall be
thine heir uh that's
uh verses four and five and verse five
says and he
brought him forth abroad and said look
now toward heaven and tell the stars if
i'll be able to number them
and he said to them so shall thy seed be
and verse 6 he believed in the lord
and he counted it to him for
righteousness it was literal yes it was
literal
abraham told god i need a child
and abram was considering making eliezer
his chief servant
as is his heir god said no no no
no someone from your own bowels would be
your heir but abraham knew his wife
could not have children
so his faith was faltering so god had to
reassure him
you will have a child but god said that
when
human conditions said impossible
we're living in a time when human
conditions say impossible
but when a person is faithful to god god
makes a way where it's impossible let me
say quickly
we talked about abraham isaac and jacob
the three patriarchs
in each one's life there was a famine
there are three famines in genesis
one in the life of abraham one in the
life of isaac one in the life of jacob
abraham went to egypt for food joseph
jacob sent his sons to egypt but
god told isaac stay right where the
famine
is i will take care of you you read us
in genesis 37
and god did and so god the key is not
the circumstance you're facing
the key is am i right with my god
because there's no circumstance god
can't handle
and god told abraham in genesis 18 verse
14 is
anything too hard for the lord of course
it's a rhetorical question
the answer is no so yes genesis 15 4 5
literal someone out of your own bowels
will be your heir
amen
you